To answer a question,
both are okay options.
This option is called software TLB
mishandling and it has the advantage of
letting the operating system use
any sort of page-table that it
wants because the hardware doesn't
really need to access the page-table.
The hardware simply has the TLB.
And the job of the operating
system is to put the correct
translations into the TLB.
But you can use any organization for
the page table it wants.
So the operating system,
for example, may not even have
the page table in form of a table.
It can use a binary tree, or
a hash table, or anything else it wants.
The second option, where the processor
automatically reads page tables and
updates the TLB is called
hardware TLB miss handling.
In this case, the page tables need to be
in a form that is easily
accessible by the hardware.
So we will have a flat or
a multi-level page table like we have
seen already in our previous videos.
This approach does require more
hardware, because the hardware now needs
to actually be able to access the page
tables and sequence the accesses to
the multiple levels and so on, but
it is faster than software handling.
This is treated kind of
like a cache miss almost,
whereas here we need to execute
a little program to fill the TLB.
So because this is faster and
because hardware is cheap these days,
most high performance processors
like x86 will use this
approach of hardware TLB mishandling.
But some embedded processors will
use the software TLB mishandling
because they're concerned
about the hardware cost.
So they want to be as
simple as possible.
And also because in this
embedded processors,
TLB misses occur frequently because they
are running more regular applications.